Hello everybody, hello, hello, welcome to my super spooky, super awesome graveyard.
Yes, thank you all for watching and thank you for being here.
How do you think of my new 3D?
very cute right yeah um yeah we have a really really awesome uh concert for you concert live concert live i never know which one to use for you guys tonight um we got new stages we got guests we got fun stuff and um i would like to thank you all so much for watching and i would also like to thank toy studios for producing this amazing amazing uh show we've got for you tonight so yeah Yeah,
are you guys ready?
Are you guys ready to be haunted by Mint Phantom?
Yeah!
Alrighty then, let's get on with the next song.
Let's go!
I'm sure you'll be
able to keep your feelings in the dark Look
at me, I want to be always Strong,
strong, strong, strong Look at the game, the start When you look at me, you'll know it's starting
Strong, strong, strong I want to tell you all, my everything I'm
trying to lie, and run away, More this way, it's a no-go-getting I don't know how to get to know It's just so far away from the back It's a bit too far too far But
it's always going to go Yoku-shi-yoku Look at the game, the start The start of the world
Yoku-shi-yoku-shi-yoku The world is so close to the world
I can't satisfy it overnight feeling like a dime
I've got to call me my bones Oh, I'm
high I want more I'm not good, but why?
I can't stop getting on Uh-oh Eiko, oh, oh, oh No, no, no, no No, no, no, no No, no, no No, no, no, no, no, No, no, no, no, no No, no, no, no Just give me more power So, you're blue
I can't
stop getting mad I
can't see no life but
I can't stop getting mad Oh, oh Oh, the know I'ma shape you all Mote a mercy, come by Oh,
the Palisone Serky-ta-deir-y own Don't give me more power
just give
Give me more power It's time to dance Let's go Go out and fight Go out and fight
Let's go Let's walk and dance Let's go
Hello everybody!
Look where we are in my favorite place ever!
Aki, how about all?
Yeah, it's so pretty, right?
Wow, wow!
But I'm not here for just any reason.
I'm here.
because I'm also meeting with some friends.
Well, some of them are friends.
You know, some of them are.
Well, you'll see.
But I guess I shouldn't waste any more time.
Let's bring in the first person.
Do-do!
Hi, honey.
I heard you were talking smack about me, so I came.
I'm always talking smack about you.
I know.
I could hear you and best of all i could smell you i could smell you the minty fresh stench oh is it how are you here i'll give it to you oh oh thank you matthew how are you enjoying yourself huh you're welcome thank you for inviting me and most importantly thank you for paying for me to come all the way here all so exciting yeah there's there's definitely uh that will go to your bank account big money big money right big big big sacks big money so talk to me why am i here what's going on um well as you can see i'm a little bit in 3d well we don't have too much time so if you want i hate to say it but i thought you looked cuter than usual oh yeah i know oh Stop it.
Stop it.
So cute.
What the heck?
Is there a pose you want to see me do before I send you away?
Yes.
I want to see your most menacing, angry pose of like, my, oh, she, I'm going to defend her honor.
Step back away from her.
I want you to enact it in your best theater.
Yeah.
Give it to me.
Give me more.
I want to see anger.
Yeah.
bashing more more now do the punching start punching start kicking yeah yeah yeah he's looking at your oh she somebody else is trying to pass you a line they're not gonna pay for their polaroid oh wait that's stealing what are you gonna do I'm gonna punch him I like how you want it one pose instead you got a whole show I know anyway honey I got a run I got a jet I got to go shopping I gotta go drinking.
Thanks for having me.
I gotta go drinking.
Yeah, go do your thing, Mata.
Bye-bye.
Matara will matane.
Wow, thank you, Matara, for being here.
But that's not all that I have invited.
So the next person, dojo.
Downward dog.
I don't know what that is.
What?
What do you mean?
Why else would I be here?
That's the same thing again.
What?
Okay, direct me.
Direct me.
Would you know what yoga?
Downward dog.
The...
Is that the one where you're like this?
No, it's the one where you get on your knees.
Get on your knees.
What are you talking about?
Oh, I don't know.
I don't actually...
Do you want to introduce yourself?
you want to introduce yourself oh yeah sorry hey guys it's me toky brain
hey guys it's me okay so i get on my knees and then and then like i don't know like you get your hands in the front and then you never done yoga before no okay by the way you don't have to get on your knees i just want you people are really gonna be like crazy about it you're seeing that okay and then wait let me google this real quick i actually don't remember what it looked like let me okay and then your hands are in the front is it like yeah and then and then no it's like it's the opposite of that is where your ass is up i don't want to do this
Okay, all right, okay, my plan be.
The camera will never face this way.
I mean, it happened twice already.
Okay, all right, all right, give me a Gannam style.
Give me a Gannam.
A what?
A Gannam style.
I know you know that, Dan.
Oh, Gannam style, okay.
Yeah, I know you know it.
You did it last time.
Hey, sexy lady.
lady oh oh oh oh oh okay okay donkey whenever your 3d happens oh yeah yeah are you planning are you pre-planning yourself i'm gonna remember i'm gonna remember all of this remember everything i've put you through yeah yeah is there anything else that you wish to torture me with soldier boy Oh You Why me You Why me Cracky Why me Oh Superman What else What else Do they do It's like Yeah Superman Yeah Superman And then You You You Does anyone Does anyone Remember this I don't I think we're showing our age Probably What do you mean It's a good song It's timeless Yeah it's true true true anyways thank you doki for being here yeah no problem at a great time bye bye had a great time i bet the whisk sits here all right see you bye bye bye bye oh maybe i shouldn't have invited doki maybe that was well i don't i i knew what i was getting myself into with that didn't i i set myself up to that most likely but we have one more person one more that is calling in someone who is i'm nervous i'm
nervous wait can i run i gotta i gotta run real quick okay okay okay okay okay okay i'm nervous okay someone that i love very very much Hi!
Hi!
You look so cute!
You are so cute!
Oh, that's so cute!
Thank you so much for having me, Dayo!
Thank you!
Thank you for being here, Dayo!
Of course, of course!
I came outside for you!
Yeah, I'm really, well, you know, I'm kind of nervous.
The last person gave me some really weird poses, but you won't do that, right?
Oh, no.
I'm, we'll see about it.
Okay, Hanya.
Okay, yeah.
Give me your, give me your worst.
A worst?
Uh, pose.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah.
Have you ever read Baki before?
Baki.
Oh, I know, but I've never read it.
There's a one Bucky post that I was maybe I'll request you.
It's very challenging.
Okay, let's see if he can do Okay, okay What is it?
Can I explain it in Japanese?
I don't think I can do it in English Okay, I'll try to understand Okay, okay, let's go Oh
Lay down and try to hold your whole body with a one hand.
You got it!
Show me your 3D polar!
Like this?
Kitsu!
No, it's close enough, but it's cute, so it's fine.
Was that right?
Ateu?
Huh?
No.
But it's fine, you're cute.
Ah, thank you.
It was a cute, it was a kawaii version of Baki pose.
Well, since you're made, I was also asking if you can do Moe Moe cute for me.
Oh, of course.
I'm a, I'm, I'm a professional at that.
Okay.
I'm getting the Moe energy.
Oh, I'm feeling it.
Okay.
I'm feeling Moe da yo.
No.
Moe.
Cue!
Hi!
Thank you, Dayo.
Thank you.
I feel very moe now.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Good.
Well, thank you, Hena, for being here for my 3D.
Thank you.
Of course.
Thank you so much for having me.
Okay, that was too much outside.
I'm time for me to go back.
Okay.
Mata ne!
Bye-bye.
Woo!
Thank you everybody for being here for my 3D.
Thank you so much, Matta and Doki and Tenya.
Thank you guys.
Well then, are you guys ready for more music?
Because it's time to keep performing.
So...
Is this...
Hold on me.
Why are you here?
I heard you were doing a live.
I heard it over here.
Did you bring me again?
Discord?
No!
You guys have never blocked her on Discord ever.
No, no, no, no.
Wow.
We'll talk about later.
Yeah, yeah, later.
It's a ma it's a mazu mazu mazu mazu maju maju maju maju Congratulations on your 3D live Look!
Kawami!
Wow you're so cute What do you think?
What do you think?
Yeah you're really um like ghost yes Yeah it's okay it's okay since I'm already here I'm so lonely I'm already here yeah you're here There's something I want to do I want to try with you.
It's okay.
Okay.
What is that?
What do you mean?
What is it?
There's a pose I want to try.
Oh, you already do.
Did many pose.
Yeah.
Are you okay?
Oh, something weird smell.
No, no.
Something smell.
You wet?
I say no.
No, no, there's no.
I'm not sweaty at all.
No, no, no.
I smell good.
Don't worry.
Let's make a bigger one so you guys can see it more easily.
Like that?
I can see it.
I can see it a little bit.
Yeah, you guys can see it obviously.
I'm 100 years old.
She's 100 years old, everybody.
She should move so much.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay.
Lastly.
I want to do that.
Hmm?
You know?
Okay, okay.
I know, I know.
Okay, let's go.
Huh?
Let's go.
See, no.
Poo, Poo, Poo, I know!
I know!
Nothing changed.
Sorry.
I'm really happy.
Our love has grown bigger.
Because of fusion.
Oh yeah.
I'm really happy.
Yeah, thank you for coming.
No touch, no touch, please.
Okay, okay.
That's fine.
I'm already going now.
Thank you, Bubba.
Don't block me again.
Push, push, don't block me.
Push, push, push, push, push.
Ice cream in the Ice cream Cutting
out my Caterpillar Spooned and scooped And I was I can't say I'm not going to say The words Hinyari Subbering The pain Eying Ice In the mouth of the Now To get the ice One Just One more One
more I love the One
dose of stress Ice cream in London The adult I love To
give you my little My little My little Scrooge I love I can't say I'm not saying I'm not Nomin' I'm not saying I'm not saying Take-C-C-C-E-C-A- I love
even more I love the showbite In the kitchen First,
ice, Kira, ice,
name, kakao,
say it
All right, All right, All right, I-oh, One more, Yuba,
Thank you for watching.
Hi!
Everybody say hello to...
Kink-kink-kink!
I am Tatumashi Kiara from Whole Life English Myth.
If you ever heard of it, I don't know.
I don't know.
You certainly heard about it.
Thank you for having me, thank you everybody!
Thank you for being cute.
It's so weird.
Like everything's so like different like here in Akihabara.
It's not where I usually perform.
Well, it's also like just different looking.
Like it's not, it's like a more magical Akihabara.
Right, everybody?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Very magical.
Yeah.
Very hot in the summer too.
It's so hot.
But yeah, this is our second time like doing something in 3D together, right?
Oh.
Yo.
Yeah, this is the second time.
I was like, wait a second.
yeah i've been performing you know it's been a long concert so oh but yeah so but this time you're here with me before i was with you on your home turf yes yeah we exchanged home turf yeah and and today's song by the way oh yeah i chose it even though it's your life i chose it there was a different song that i was like kiara owned it i was like this song would suit kiara I think so it'd be really cute for us to do it and then you were like oh can we change this is better sorry but it was so cute and I think it fits the vibe better actually yeah I think it's good I just know what's best anyway oh you do is your throat okay perhaps we should not talk so much oh you know it's been oh yeah I've been singing a whole lot and so I'm a little tired I thought of something we could do oh really together what could it be what could it possibly what do idols like do all the time what do vtubers do all the time oh especially in 3d now that we have 3d well i have 3d you have you have had yes but wow
let's do charades oh wow so exciting oh my gosh nobody could have guessed that it's going to be good though i found a very difficult specific situations.
Me too.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
We came up with some very unique things.
It's not like, oh, I'm a dog.
Oh, I'm a bird.
I'm a bird.
You are.
Yes.
I'm not a dog.
Oh, I'm a ghost.
Why are you saying that?
Okay.
You start?
Okay, I'll start.
Okay.
The first situation.
Yes.
Okay.
Well, this is more of an action.
I don't know.
Okay.
I can't talk.
I'm observing.
Okay.
Wait, it's somehow that looks familiar.
I don't know what it is.
Um, um, um, um, uh, oh god, I'm bad.
Are you doing like a, like a lasso?
You're like a cowboy.
You're a cowboy?
No?
On the horse?
No.
Um, um, um, um.
Close, close.
You're ringing a bell in the church.
No, you're...
How is that close?
You're the lady that does shame.
How was that close to cowboy?
You're close to cowboy.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What's close to a cowboy?
Hand-training.
Hand-training?
Maybe cowboys, it's not a horse.
Not a horse.
It's a donkey.
You're a shrek.
Okay, it's not a horse.
Is that a donkey?
What else can you ride on?
It's really crazy.
It's like throwing me up.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
It's a rodeo machine.
Bing boy.
I know.
Okay.
I know where you got that from.
One point for me, I guess.
Okay.
Well, I mean, you got a lot of hints.
So is it really a point if it's like...
Wow.
Okay.
We'll see how it goes with my...
Okay, okay, go dojo.
Okay, three, two, one, start.
You're already laughing.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
I can't...
You're a comedian.
You're a clown.
You're showing off...
Oh, you go to a store, a department store, and they tell you the dress that it looks good on you.
Oh, oh.
and let's get on me now oh oh i think i'll buy it oh i'm you you are the sales attendant yes oh in a department store yeah oh okay but i was just the only reason you got it that fast was because i explained it really well i showed it really well actually it was like true mine like it was like i could see it so i was looking i saw the dress yes for real yeah okay okay ding ding ding ding Okay.
Okay.
You.
Your turn.
Me too.
Okay.
This is a situation.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Start.
Situation.
Uh, you're literally at my concert supporting me.
No?
Oh, you're like really far.
You're at, you're at Holofus, but you're, you have a seat really far in the back.
You can barely see the idols on stage.
No?
Okay.
Well, you are an otaku.
You're like a fan, right?
Like a...
Uh-huh.
You're holding a sign.
You're trying to have the idol see what's on your sign.
Or you just see you.
Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, you're ping, ping, ping, ping, ping.
It was a fan who was not, who was trying to get Fansa from their idol, but she wouldn't give Fansa to them.
So he's like, oh, she's like jumps, the jumps.
When you're really desperate.
Yeah, yeah, desperate.
Here, here, here, here.
Me too, come on here.
Yeah, but it's bad.
Wow, you got it though.
You got it.
Biffon, biffon, biffon.
Biffon, biffon!
Okay.
The situation?
Yes.
Okay.
No.
It's a...
It's a thing.
A thing.
Some people...
Whatever.
You'll see.
Okay.
Um...
Hmm?
What?
Wait, wait?
Oh, okay.
Wait, wait.
I don't know what it is.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Look closely.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Wait, you have to also consider I'm left-handed.
Maybe.
Okay.
No.
Okay, wait, look, look.
I did this, right?
What do I have in my left hand?
Hint, hint, hint, hint!
What do I have in my left hand when I go like this?
Scissors?
You did this!
Yeah!
Similar.
Here, I take a fresh one.
Take a fresh one.
I give up.
I give up!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
This is so easy!
Okay!
Do you guys get it?
Hint is I'm in the restaurant.
Yeah, I guess you're making a food.
Not making it.
I was served the food.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
So here's the food.
Here is...
What is this?
A spoon.
Yeah.
And here I have the...
The...
Oh, the men?
The noodles?
The chopsticks?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
Okay, now you know that.
So...
Takoyaki.
Ice cream.
Do you want to know it?
Yeah, I want to know it.
It's making a mini-rame.
Mini?
That's what I do.
That's how I eat ramen.
Like, I put everything on the ramen spoon.
And then...
Ah, it's a very Kiara-specific...
You don't get a point!
I win!
He had a no-katee!
But I want to hear the rest too!
Wait, my last one?
Yeah.
And then my last one, I want to hear that one.
We are almost out of time.
Okay, do we get last one?
Your chance to get one point.
Oh, I remember.
Okay, I remember.
Start.
Ah, you're serving like whipped cream on an exploded.
You're serving something on an exploded.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, you're working at a restaurant.
and you're doing the oh nice let the ketchup and then it exploded or like it did like a mess and you and she's like oh and then you're wiping it up is a genius you got it exactly right i've been to a fair share of made cafes myself have you ever been exploded upon exploited exploded uh have i ever been exploded
Anyway, it's not a short time.
Let's take one cute picture together.
Everybody can screenshot it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then, yes.
Oh, heart.
I can't really do it well.
Everybody screenshot, screenshot, screenshot.
Were you gonna do the thing?
Oh.
There we go.
Yay, screenshot, screenshot, screenshot.
Thank you for coming, Mikiwa.
I love you!
Okay.
Goodbye.
Have fun with her.
If you don't need her anymore, send her back to me.
Go!
Bye bye!
Bye!
Okay.
Are you guys ready for the next song here in wonderful Akihaburo?
Let's go!
1.1 1.1 1.1 1.2.
2.5.
1.2.
1.1.
20.
9.
I like.
5.
11.
9.
from the heart so you are the you are I
want I want more soon the time is 8
year old year and away there's no
Or you don't know what's going on.
The moon is already hitting me.
I'll get
it.
I'll get it in the middle.
It's a little bit more.
It's a big moon.
It's
a big, lovely, lovely.
all too bright.
Hello everybody!
We have once again changed locations and I got to sing with my favorite girlies ever, Phoebe and Vicky.
You know, of course, one day, one day we will all sing together in 3D on a stage, so look forward to it.
But do you know where we are?
it's a it's a very big it's it's a stage that many many performers want to perform at so maybe one day we'll perform at the real Budokan but for now we're on this very beautiful I mean this stage is still very very beautiful right It looks so delicious.
Oh, it looks so delicious.
But yeah, I'm just really, really grateful.
And I'm starting to get a little emotional.
But I'm really happy that I could be here with all my friends and with you guys.
And that we could deliver this really, really, really awesome show.
Sorry, my brain is all...
But not over yet.
It's not, not yet.
We still have time.
So there's a few more songs that I want to sing and dance for you.
And yeah, are you guys ready?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, minto.
Minto, minto, minto, minto.
Okay, the next song is very, very special to me.
So keep it kudos.
YAMEL TOK SQUOYAKNAR TOTY WATASI DEI EIRUKOTO YAMI
DAKIIMETE HUSI DEMO DARRENIY I can't even tell you No, no, no, no, no DARRS DARRS DARRS DARRS DARRS DARRS DARRS DARRS
DARRS me
I'm always trying to get to know where I'm going to go, but I'm not going to follow my
own feelings.
I'm always happy to give it to you.
I'm alone,
I'm always proud
of myself.
I'm so glad I
came to be happy with you.
I want to talk to you.
I'm happy for you to help me.
I'm a great person.
I'm alive and I want to know For each of the time of me I'm at the moment when I'm happy, I'm at the moment For me, I'm at the moment Thank you for being here Thank you for being here I'm in my room I'm in my room I want to tell you What
is the truth?
When you're in the same morning The world is gone
It's only time
When you come together You're in a new world Chuh-chuh, yeah I
love you, I'm a new人-her That dreamer
I'm a natural type
of combination But it's not
your own combination But no matter what the world is It's a dark,
tender Rhythm, the harsh dark Yeah,
the same time
how was it you guys the the walkway right amazing huh budokan budokan but unfortunately i must say that we are close to the end of the show I have a ghost don't get tired no way I could still go for for so long but um yeah I just wanted to say one more time thank you so so so so much everybody for you know I wouldn't be able to stand here with this amazing crowd without all of your support and thank you again to all my friends who joined me today and we all danced and had a good time and did silly poses and it was a lot of fun and I hope you guys had a lot of fun too and yeah I'm just I'm so so so grateful and oh thank you again also Toy Studios for the amazing amazing production of this show so oh yes um i i feel very it's very satisfied right so last song but but since it's the last song i want to introduce my original song yes finally
So, yeah, in this beautiful stage, I will debut my first original song.
So I would like to welcome you to my made coffee.
Let's go.
.
I have you.
Hello everybody.
Wait, wait, I want to...
This is Minto from the other side.
And tomorrow I will be releasing...
Wait, why am I doing this voice if I'm talking?
Wait, hold on.
Minto has merch coming out.
Tomorrow.
I'm here to show it to, as we do.
One second.
I forgot to prepare it before the show.
Please look.
Ta-da!
T-shirt!
Stand-in!
Lap blanket!
it, slippers, fumo style plushie, all pre-orders tomorrow.
Thank you.